But the the main point is that Sharia,
Islamic law, Islamic uh
uh hegemony must be in place. That's the
concept of Jihad in the doctrine. We can
talk about verses and so forth, but the
second
explanation, which I find much more
compelling,
is not the doctrinal argument, even
though it's there. The doctrinal
argument is there. But the problem is a
lot of people will rightfully argue and
say, "Well, look at the Bible. The Old
Testament's full of violence, you know,
so what's your point?" Well, a lot of
Christians and Jews are not doing that
sort of thing. Um so I So my take has
always been, "Okay, fine. Let's park the
scriptures and let's see what happened
historically."
And lo and behold, if you study the real
history of Islam and the West, it is one
of unmitigated Jihad and conquest. Most
people aren't aware that in the 7th
century when Islam essentially burst out
of Arabia,
um just from the year that Muhammad
dies, 632 to 732,
which is the Battle of Tours in the
middle French French, um Muslims
conquered literally almost three
quarters of what was once the Christian
world. Most people aren't aware that
when you talk about Christendom before
Islam, the majority of it is in what we
now call the Middle East and North
Africa, MENA, Muslim world. So Egypt,
Syria, you know, Lebanon, Iraq, Jordan,
Israel, that land, the PA territories,
all of Turkey, Asia Minor, all of Egypt,
Libya, Tunisia, Algeria,
Morocco, Spain. Okay, all those were
Christian and they all got conquered.
Spain, of course, is still Christian.
Until they got into the middle of
France. And then later, um you had
another several iterations of Jihad
which burst out and one of the most
fierce was the Ottoman
Turks and they again invaded and they
conquered the Balkans and you know,
Constantinople. And in 1683,
now we're talking a millennium after
Muhammad's time, they're surrounding
Vienna and on the verge of conquering
it. And then there were the mass slave
raids that left virtually no part of
Europe, including Iceland, untouched.
North African Barbary pirates would go
as far as north
Iceland. They had a island base off
Britain called Lundy and they would
terrorize and and go ransacking and get
slaves. In one in about a one century
era, all right, in the 16th century,
there was 1.2 million European white
Christian slaves being sold in North
Africa. [clears throat] That's just from
Barbary.
Um the Ottomans and then the Tatars, the
Crimean the Crimean Khanates and the
Golden Horde, which were Muslims, they
enslaved multiples and multiples of
millions as well. And just to cap it
off, America's very first war as a
nation is with Muslims thinking again on
that same rationale. And it's so very
telling because all you have to So what
I'm referring to, of course, is the
Barbary War, first one, which flares out
around 1800, but in the years before
that, these the same Muslim pirates were
ransacking American vessels, kidnapping
and enslaving soldiers. And long story
short, find at one point the US was
spending 16% of its federal budget to
appease them so they stopped doing that.
And then they finally Thomas Jefferson
and John Adams met with one of the
ambassadors from Barbary.
And it's it's it's remarkable cuz we
have preserved his letter to Congress
and what he says. And he basically says,
"We took the time to explain to them we
have no beef against anyone, whatever
religion. We Why don't we work together?
Why don't we engage in trade?" And then
he writes back what the ambassador told
him, told Jefferson and Adams, which was
basically,
"It is our religion. It is our prophet.
It is our Quran. All of these call on
and call you the infidel. It is our
right to kill you, attack you, plunder
you. And any of us who die go to
heaven." Okay? So that's straight out of
ISIS. Okay? So what I've just given you
this This is a quick encapsulation from
the time of Muhammad
to Ameri So we're talking 1,200 years
now. And this is what I said, let's park
the doctrine, the books, the Quran, and
let's see what actually happened. And
what happened, of course, is just one
long non-stop Jihad, different
iterations and vicissitudes, of course.
Um and like I said, three quarters of
the Christian world, the older, richer,
more sophisticated, more theologically
advanced region, which no no one
connects with Christianity, like Egypt
and Syria and Asia Minor, Turkey, were
all swallowed up by um So So when you
ask about, you know, the question, you
know, are they Is this struggle
intrinsic? I would say, "Yes, from the
Islamic side." Okay? We've seen the
doctrine, but the history has been the
way it is. The only reason it ever
stopped was because it was physically
stopped by the West.
Bring back the fire.
Bring back the
the fire
and the righteous